yeah I come to this video against Prince
panic from the Netherlands and here we
had this before just some games before
and curious if he has got something else
prepared now or something at least he's
playing oldest quicker now
yeah Queenie falls really the move that
they all play not so says something else
Bishop f4 many
and there were one ideas to go e 6am but
should be formed as a pretty big check
so he's still spending tons of time
Queenie for is really the move to go
yeah but ok Bishop f4 let's let's see
let's say you would play Bishop before
go I do a go eat six on some other move
Knight g 696 can also play 96 ok long
castles is what he played in in the
other game
this should be 3 Bishop f5 this is what
we had before
yeah this is funny
I think Bishop f4 has also moved if I
remember correctly it's a while that I
yeah it's been a while that I did that I
produced the series the idea is that
Bishop f5 now is prepared and if he
takes there's even Bishop age six and
some in some positions okay Knight to f3
our Bishop f5 looks normal
ok so just exchange yeah just exchange
mm-hmm I don't have any big begin to
Ricky I am
mercy form
night see for Bishop Roxy aid and b5
yeah I probably need to have this kind
of trick otherwise I'm worse and that's
the only drawback of his position it's
got the king and exposed on the C file
Bishop takes rook c8 and b5 coming
yeah the problem is I'm also threatening
rook c8 just going for an attack on the
King so he doesn't have like rook e1 or
something some some some slow moves yeah
I whoopsie a tower thought hmm yeah I
cannot retreat the bishop this is
complete completely out of the question
I need to do this we can take now and
then i can play night somewhere III OD
six and then take on a five with the
light it's still not a clear-cut
position or is there something else no
probably not yeah
yeah I still have some some positional
deficit cf-30 in this position it's just
the pawn is nice but he's got bishops
and my position is not exactly a picture
of harmony may be here I need to get my
stuff out
yes yeah yeah of course the question is
what now do I go can i play five or is
this is this just just not on
what is the threat maybe can tear taking
him
I have Roxy five this is very important
I have Roxy 5d 795 so can play such a
slow mph or maybe he can okay I don't
think I'm I need to need this temple
yeah i think it's it's under control now
or to you form
to your point go go for a five min
you forgot about the smooth
okay come on keep it simple take him and
then we can take now on b7 wat it's an
extra porn and 94 even some pretty
decent coordination all right yes spent
a very much another too much time in the
beginning I I'm not the one to criticize
people for time management I'm so I'm
the one to lose on time all the time he
spent ages here and this we had this
just a couple of hours ago in this in
this long ish session um yeah this is
this is really really the way to play
turn very difficult very difficult
maybe he can take it's all not so
clear-cut you are not so clear even this
I thought even this wasn't wasn't so
clear I mean look at the the pieces he's
got the two bishops and I've got a
couple of a couple of ugly things he
success we call this is a bit too yeah I
need to need one or two moves too yeah
and I have the computer running in the
background now and at the points out
that rook see one is slightly better for
what I can sit sir it's possible let's
just have a brief look here yeah oops
this is maybe helping me or no yeah yeah
I'm not I'm not well developed here
computer wants to play this but it looks
um it looks very very problematic yeah
probably i need to do to do something
else before this is where I don't know
bit fishy disposition yeah thanks for
watching this game